okay so some aspects of the drill of
course
work on your biomechanics here your body
mechanics
but also work on the on the reading so
you want to hit before that thing comes
out i'm not hitting this
and then hold and then i go out it's
just like kimusubi
on shomanuchi so we're down here right
and he goes shomanuchi i have to be able
to read that i can't wait
so the same thing we're here and i'm
hitting him
only in slow motion do you see that he
actually started first and then i went
okay but this got to be obviously wrong
that is never gonna happen okay so
in and then pay attention to the right
hand
if i need it i can pop but otherwise
don't drop the right hand
have the right hand ready to follow the
jab back boom
and we're going to move in our whole
mask and displace it
okay so top and bottom in when i move in
boom i'm very compact still
cut and
okay up hands up elbows down come back
okay go okay so i i'm not boxing that
minion i'm not out here
please i'm not out here and i'm trying
to hit this
okay i'm out here and my goal is to
close the gap
where i can start to take control and
we're not in an exchanging a blows
situation
but to do that i'm going to
do it with a strike
that's why my body is moving in so boom
my body's moving into close so let's say
it doesn't have that
i'm here to boom and pop i'm in
you see
so i'm just going to take that inside
thought boom
boom i'm in it i'm gonna kick that
inside thigh out
right here boom right in there okay so
i'm gonna kick the inside thigh
and just push
so i'm going to pull the strike a little
and he's going to take a little leukemia
[Music]
do you see how i'm closing the gap as
opposed to i'm out here
boom and i'm going to try to hit that
she's going to hit me
so i closed it
okay let's go okay so when i'm doing uh
for example
his body has to come forward whoa
there's that leg right there and then i
get the back outward pattern
okay same thing goes on if you not yet i
have to bring this leg forward and then
do my technique i cannot
bend people button him over that doesn't
happen
i can tilt him okay so
when i'm doing this technique it's the
same kazushi pattern
once i kick this leg up you're going to
see it
right there just hang out for me you can
hold on if you want you see it right
there i'm going to move to the other
side
here it is right here
so you already know that kazushi powder
and you're just going to hit it
okay
let's go okay so now i'm going to take
something that he was doing so he was
bridging the gap with a strike
okay here you want to stay out there and
and
exchange blows with me which is smart
okay he wants to get inside and get some
sort of dominance gun
okay so i throw that jab he throws his
jab
and then he follows it back in with his
body moving do you think his body moves
yes let's try it again you're looking to
close the gap
okay so one moves his body in
okay that's what we're gonna use here
so i'll throw my jab i'm gonna paw his
jab
bring my jab back and let that thing go
by
i'm looking for that cross boom boom
let it go by and i get back here
you see where i am
let it go by i'm back here on this back
corner
let it go by
let it go back down
there
uh and my other hand is always involved
in in the technique so it always fills
the openings for example i don't do
i'm not going to do some good touch like
this see because my face is open
oh my other hand always feels open so as
his arm is occupied
being occupied with his own grip in the
technique and his forward progress
right it's going to allow me to get the
cross check then the
hand can fill that gap meaning
i won't put it back here it's not doing
anything
i won't put it over here right i won't
put it over here either
okay it has a place to be
it looks for work and it positions
itself where it can do work
so when i'm in this in-fighting position
it's the same thing i don't
i don't i'm not going to drop my hand my
hand is in the position
where it could do the work that is
required for in-fighting
okay so i'm the first dude
so he's throwing his jab my right hand
is looking for this thing to get out of
the way
boom is what i'm hitting
oh i put it where it can do its job
boom now we switch rolls
okay so he goes my right hand
is here okay my right hand won't do
anything over here
so boom i'm here and now
i know from my training for my dilemma
that the left jab usually
leads the right hand so i'm looking for
that hand
so when i come back i don't want to
take my hands and do something like that
so we're here as these hands go back
right now my hands are doing nothing for
this
doing nothing for this infant and that's
where
the traditional martial artist has lost
sight of the principle
and is now doing a form which is mis
being misapplied okay so in the same way
that this hand is where the work could
be done
as he comes back this hand stays where
the work can be done
so it did what it needed to do
[Music]
and only what it needed to do
that's why i don't drop my house boom
boom i'm over here because i'm looking
for that because i saw that
so we're gonna go we'll do two little
variations
so this one's going to go here
boom to hit which is more reason why i
bought my hands
up so i hit as he's striking again
okay so i'm going to hit as he's
striking
i'm going to grab the head and you're
going to have the front
inward kazushi pattern right here
so boom boom in you know
that same knee kick i'm just going to
pick this leg
up and around
then i have the technique one
boom in and right
okay let's
he moves in i hit okay
and now i'm i'm on this back corner okay
so
what i'm going to do is seek uh more
more back corner okay so what's he want
to do
he wants to follow me you see so
i see more about corner he follows me
and then
i have pura the first one i had a motive
and now i have buddha because my final
geometry
boom changed and went to the spiral
you see and so it goes to the spiral i
pull the head down
find the leg
boom i start to move he moves
decisions i'm looking for the spiral
geometry that's in all my kinhon laws
okay
so here here and
boom what i'm doing here is trying to
get back here
so it looks something like this if he
stays still
but in the same way that i'm looking for
the right
once the left comes the same way when i
go
here i'm looking for this turn
yes i'm aware of the back hand but after
he throws this
hand and he pulls it back because that's
what he's trying to do
it's very awkward to do that i'm aware
of it though
so when i get here i can play the setup
he's going to want to turn
into me and when he turns into me
that's where i have
[Music]
the only difference is i'm head and leg
okay let's go so to train in terms of
principle
is to actually apply things that are
consistent with what you're seeing in
your kihon was it
it's not to plug and play
that is that is a very beginner level
understanding
but so too then i don't um
necessarily then do things exactly the
same way
okay so for example this is what you'll
tend to do so i go one
and two and then i'm gonna go here
you see and i'm gonna try to pull his
head down
here but this is a perfectly balanced
person and that is not consistent with
my kihon waza principles
so i to go like this just pretend please
i pull his head down and i come around
thought
you're going to be in for the same
wake-up call
that that aikidoka gets whenever they go
with the non-choreographed phuket
well i'm just standing here you didn't
do anything okay
so when you do for example uh
nagi you see you lower his head your
lowest head
makes the back half life he's off
balance
by things i do prior to the throw
so the same thing goes here so when i'm
going one
two and i'm moving this way that
is what i'm looking for that's the
energy i use
and that's consistent with kihon masa
not
doing kijoon masa strangely here
that's not consistent because he's
perfectly balanced
so when i do the maneuver boom i'm
moving here my guard is up
i'm not going for his neck yet
i'm moving here
because that's where my hands need to be
to do the work that is needed
so one two i move that's what i want
so when he does that then i have the
energy that i harmonize with and it's
then that i'm consistent with my
team and laza okay try it again